i'm afraid what are we doing to our
young people no no stop over we're not
doing jack [ __ ] this is what's happening
there's no we are doing this is the
reality of human evolution how can i
stop feeling insecure about myself
online why do i feel like everyone
online hates me how do i keep my child
safe from the dangers of the internet
what can i do to protect myself don't
want to [ __ ] get posted what advice
are you telling your kids about the
internet
okay you know what though gary you're a
dad what are you gonna do when your
daughter is 14 and she's locked in her
room desperate to make selfies and
videos that people care about when she
walks out of room and says no one likes
me in this world i think about this a
lot this is my number one thing that i'm
most passionate about period in the end
the world number one way to protect the
child
is to build their self-esteem
[Music]
guess what
you suck at a ton of
good so does everybody else you're also
probably pretty rad at something try as
many things as possible until you figure
out what you're rad at and you like and
go do that for the rest of your life
most of all what i care about is trying
to have a conversation around
self-esteem eliminating envy completely
tuning out the judgment of others who
have no context on your actual truth and
trying to find a way to live within the
means of your reality i actually fear
kids that are really good at school or
really good looking i'm being serious
because their entire framework from the
world is getting affirmation from those
two things so the very attractive when
they start hitting that 40s 50s 60s 70s
go into some very dark places
because if the world has been telling
you this is why you're good
you're like [ __ ] like like right your
number one responsibility if you care
about somebody underneath you whether
that's your child or your student or
your teammate or whatever your number
one responsibility
is to understand what you're affirming
what we cheer for for our children
become their framework if we cheer that
they're so good looking they start to
find value in their looks and become
vulnerable in their 50s and 60s and 70s
and 80s if we cheer for their sports
acumen and like they're going to be a
pro and then they're not they're lost at
22. when a child
is not insecure
they don't succumb to danger if you make
her confident in who she is that she's
amazing the way she is she will not
succumb to other people
and that is how she will navigate
ultimately i believe the biggest miss in
the world is people focusing on things
that don't matter and underestimating
the things that matter focusing on the
things that matter most and building up
self-esteem around that and then
suffocating and muting the stuff society
values because in reality long-term it
doesn't matter as much we are strong as
[ __ ] we're really [ __ ] strong we're
just being sold that we're not because
there's a lot of money in telling us
that we're not pretty enough thin enough
smart enough good enough [ __ ] that i
want to tell you you're the [ __ ] best
go do [ __ ]